Disney+'s "Loki" is off to a fantastic start,
with the first two episodes positively packed
with fun details and homages for Marvel Comics
fans to find.
Here are some Easter eggs in Episode 2 you
may have missed.
At the beginning of Episode 2, several Minutemen
travel to Oshkosh, Wisconsin, in 1985.
They arrive at a Renaissance Faire where they
believe the Loki variant is hiding out.
At first, it might appear like Oshkosh is
a totally random place for the writers and
producers of "Loki" to select for a scene
like this, but there's actually a sweet story behind it.
Mark Gruenwald was a prolific Marvel Comics
writer, editor, penciler, and celebrated Marvel
continuity expert, which is why the appearance
of the comic book version of Mobius is based
on Gruenwald, and why Owen Wilson gets to
sport a moustache in the show.
Mobius's appearance isn't the only homage
"Loki" pays to the late comic book legend,
as it turns out he was also born in Oshkosh,
Wisconsin, according to his New York Times obituary.
Gruenwald died at age 43 following a heart
attack in 1996.
There are hundreds of floors that make up
the TVA, which is full of winding hallways
and curvy architectural designs.
Loki and Mobius take several elevator rides
throughout the first few episodes, traveling
to all different kinds of TVA departments.
In Episode 2, they land on level 372, where
Mobius instructs Loki to read through all
of the variant's paperwork to see if he can
come up with any theories or suggestions.
Why 372?
The Time Variance Authority made its first
appearance in "Thor" volume 1, issue #372.
The use of 372 as one of the floor numbers
in "Loki" is a nice nod to the organization's
origins and suggests viewers should probably
take a second look at all numbers that pop
up in the series.
Loki can only access his own file at the TVA,
so we get to witness Loki read about the events
of Ragnarok, which he hasn't lived through
at this point in time.
While he's looking through the documents,
we see some new tidbits of information about
the event that we witnessed in "Thor: Ragnarok."
The paperwork shows that there were 9,719
casualties in what's described as a Class Seven Apocalypse.
Mobius confirms that Ragnarok wiped out "most"
of Asgard's people, and we know from "Avengers:
Endgame" that the survivors are currently
living on Earth in New Asgard.
A more light-hearted easter egg hidden in
the Ragnarok paperwork is the mention of the Revengers.
The makeshift superhero group is assembled
by Thor and includes Valkyrie , the Hulk, and Loki.
The foursome bond together to escape Sakaar
and are instrumental in the takedown of Hela.
Thor jokes about their group name in the film,
but the group helped save hundreds of Asgardians
from death — justifying their mention on
the document.
In Episode 2, Loki, Mobius, and a team of
Minutemen travel to Alabama in 2050.
They're there to sniff out the missing variant
who Loki suspects is hiding in apocalyptic events.
The group arrives in a Roxxcart parking lot,
and the store name is too reminiscent of a
famous Marvel Comics corporation to be ignored.
The Roxxon Corporation - which has gone by
many names - is an oil conglomerate that was
first mentioned in 1974's "Captain America"
#180.
Clearly this is the same company now.
Roxxcart has worked with both SHIELD and HYDRA,
but their alliance will always lie with whoever
can fill their pockets the most.
Blinded by dollar signs, Roxxcart deals in
heavily illicit activities, sometimes with
the universe's biggest villains.
In "Thor" #6 Vol. 4, Roxxon worked closely
with Malekith to receive exclusive rights
to mine on any planets he overtook.
In the MCU, the corporation was mentioned
by the Mandarin in "Iron Man 3."
"Thomas here is an accountant for the Roxxon
Oil Corporation."
And the brand has been featured in other Marvel
live-action TV projects, including Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
There’s been a long standing rumor that
Lady Loki would make an appearance in Loki,
so when a female antagonist popped up toward
the end of Episode 2, a casual fan and rumor-follower
might just assume that we’ve got ourselves
a Lady Loki!
Well… not so fast my friend.
In the English credits at the end of the episode,
actress Sophia Di Martino is listed as playing “The Variant”.
However, if you look at the Spanish credits,
Elisa Beuter is credited as playing Sylvie.
That name might ring a bell to long-time Marvel
fans.
It seems likely this Variant is actually Enchantress
- a character who first battled Thor way back
in 1964 in Journey Into Mystery issue 103.
Enchantress’s real name is indeed Sylvie.
Now, we’ve seen the MCU get cute before
with cameos and such - looking at you Wandavision
- so we can’t guarantee you that this is
Enchantress.
Lady Loki still might pop up eventually in
the series, or this is another of those silly
MCU twists Enchantress is the new Lady Loki.
After The Variant sets off multiple reset
charges at Roxxcart in 2050, the sacred timeline
is thrust into chaos.
As Judge Renslayer watches the pandemonium
in her office, her computer screen displays
several locations that appear to be affected
by all of the meddling.
While some of these locations we've seen on
more than one occasion in the MCU - like Asgard
and Vormir - the others we only visited once.
Hala is the Kree home planet and the one that
Carol Danvers trained on for many years, and
it appeared in "Captain Marvel."
Xandar made its appearance in "Guardians of
the Galaxy," but we know the planet was decimated
by Thanos just before the events of "Avengers:
Infinity War."
In "Thor: Ragnarok," we visited the trash
planet of Sakaar, which the Grandmaster oversees,
while Titan is the home planet of Thanos that
saw an epic battle between the villain and
part of the Avengers in "Infinity War."
Ego is, of course, the living planet, and
the setting for about half of "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Loki"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.